I'm worried about synthetic biology
getting out of control that is someone
creating a novel organism they don't
fully understand and then it does
something disastrous to the environment
apart from aging and hair loss I'm
worried by global warming which is the
great issue in front of us and the huge
extinction of species going on at the
moment both caused by there being more
hominids on the planet than it can
easily sustain climate change is an
issue that as some colleagues have put
it has a huge procrastination penalty as
we delay action to curtail greenhouse
gas emissions it becomes more and more
difficult to stabilize those greenhouse
gas concentrations at a level that isn't
dangerous so my concern is that that we
don't respond to that challenge fast
enough what worries me fundamentally is
humanity's capacity for evil it's not
unique to any period we are the kinds of
animals that do horrible things to each
other and we can't deny that and live
happily ever after as some people would
like to the other thing that really
worries me is the rise of fundamentalism
particularly fundamental religions
tribalism political religious economic
ideologies that are embedded in tribes
and tribalism the whole xenophobia us
against them the good guys the bad guys
that's an evolved characteristic of our
species it's the dark side of human
nature it's not going to go away we have
to be eternally vigilant not just for
freedom but also on the other end to
protect our freedoms from these tribal
tendencies that worry me people being
illogical people being irrational people
who look at the data but still don't see
the pattern that frightens me I worry
that people don't care enough about
educating their kids about science math
and engineering for the United States
something has to happen next because
we're in crisis when it comes to
it's in math we've got to change the way
we educate our kids and we've got to
invest much more in basic science
infrastructure for the entire country
well I think mortality you know it
really sucks that we're all going to die
and that's just that's just the fact of
it so it worries me you know of course
the notion of immortality probably
worries me too I wouldn't want to just
keep drifting on forever but mortality
really should worry us all don't you
think I shouldn't say that smiling
should I and what it's true what worries
me about the web and the direction that
we're going with communication
technologies is how little serendipity
there is I used to have so much
serendipity in the library and they
don't go to library anymore I never go
to libraries I can get all of my
information online the web is it was an
ideal world in which we would you know
meet people from around the world with
different ideas different opinions but
it seems to me that increasingly the way
that we're consuming media the way that
we're consuming news the way that we are
interacting with information is is more
and more funneled through our friends
and our contacts which just simply
serves to confirm our biases at amazon
it's designed to show you what else you
would like rather than something that
you might just come across and
newspapers and the whole the whole works
it's just a little less magical than it
used to be and ultimately it reduces our
perspective and it means that we have
less serendipity to learn about new
perspectives new ideas and a whole new
ways of looking at the world I'm pretty
optimistic I think things are generally
better now than they've ever been before
and I don't see that trend stopping
you